Ciao Buon pomeriggio a tutti
Eccomi Oggi parlerò del fatto che tutti
abbiamo un perché dobbiamo scoprirlo Per
far sì che possa essere il nostro motore
parto da un post che ho condiviso sui
miei canali Instagram
raccontava di una sensazione che ho
provato ho provato questa sensazione di
dovermi mettere dentro una scatola di
dover incanalare tutto quello che gli
avevo fatto nella vita in un'unica
parola volevo che la mia professione e
la mia persona potessero coincidere in
modo perfetto questo perché vedevo le
persone intorno a me essere così
centrate così felici di quello che
facevano Io però non riuscivo a trovare
il mio orizzonte
è stato così fino a quando non ho
ascoltato proprio un Temple quello di
Emily watnic dal titolo Perché alcuni di
noi non hanno una singola vocazione
Cos'è un multi potenziale un
multipotenziale è una persona che ha più
Talenti applicati a più settori in
generale un individuo curioso creativo
che può però annoiarsi facilmente
per dirla in termini spicci un
multipotenziale è il contrario di uno
specialista prima di conoscere questo
termine appunto mi sono sentita
inadeguata questo perché Perché
dal mondo dell'università dove
ho studiato una materia che poi
abbandonata Mi sono laureata in un
settore per poi specializzarmi con un
master in tutt'altro questo si è
traslato poi al mondo del lavoro ho
fatto più professioni alcune delle quali
contemporaneamente
ufficio stampa nella moda
società di consulenza agenzia
pubblicitaria e nel frattempo ho
lanciato e fatto fallire una startup
ognuna di queste strade mi sembrava la
strada giusta Quella che avrebbe potuto
rappresentarmi come individuo
La verità è che poi in fondo non era mai
così e questo si è trasformato in un
pensiero più oscuro quello di non avere
nulla da dare e poi in uno più pratico
quello di non riuscire a costruirmi un
futuro stabile Eppure mi dicevo da
bambina quando mi chiedevano Carolina
Qual è il tuo lavoro dei sogni cosa
vorresti fare da grande io una risposta
la trovavo sempre dalla più banale
la veterinaria Quanti di voi potete
alzare la mano Quanti di voi almeno una
volta nella vita non hanno sognato di
fare la veterinaria o il veterinario e
poi uno un po' più particolare La
benzinaia adoravo l'odore della benzina
quando andava a fare il pieno con mia
mamma
la psicologa questo Forse diventando un
po' più grande ho compreso quanto fosse
necessario un po' rendersi conto di
quello che avevamo intorno
Ecco la verità è che forse è proprio qui
che inizia il turbamento Quando ad una
domanda aperta ci viene chiesto di
rispondere Con un'unica parola
il tetto di Emily wapnik mi ha aiutato a
sentirmi vista riconosciuta
la parte più razionale di me aveva
compreso di poter vivere facendo più
cose diverse di Non doversi sentire in
colpa a non avere un'unica risposta alla
domanda Cosa fai nella vita
quella più emotiva però continuava ad
avere paura e da qui che entra in gioco
il perché
il primo incontro con il mio perché il
primo incontro con il mio perché è stato
durante il lockdown un giorno
spinta da qualcosa che solo ora riesco a
spiegarvi e a spiegarmi ho preso L'unico
strumento che aveva a disposizione il
telefono e ho cominciato ad intervistare
i professionisti da settori diversi
ne ho intervistati più di 80 in 90
giorni ogni giorno della mia sala da
pranzo
con un indole un filo masochista direi
ho proprio pensato a quelle persone che
mi era capitato di invidiare negli anni
quelle persone che avevano la luce negli
occhi parlando del proprio lavoro
da Diego chef di successo in una
trattoria di Milano a Clemente
organizzatore di grandi eventi sino a
Veronica imprenditrice nel settore dei
gioielli
Ecco il mio perché è stata
quell'inconsapevole spinta cos'è il
perché il perché non è un talento
specifico è un filo invisibile a volte
che lega tutto quello che abbiamo fatto
nella vita è quello che ci dà la voglia
di fare quello che ci eccita ora non
tutti hanno bisogno di trovare il
proprio perché nel mondo del lavoro ci
sono professioni che hanno il perché un
po' intrinseco proprio in quello che
portano al mondo vi faccio l'esempio del
medico che vuole prendersi cura degli
altri del professore che vuole divulgare
conoscenza e poi dell'attore per esempio
che vuole emozionare ed emozionarsi Poi
però ci sono persone come me come Forse
alcuni di voi qui in sala che non hanno
un unico salvadanaio Dove mettere tutte
le proprie monete Ecco noi ci possiamo
sentire persi in realtà la verità è che
una missione l'abbiamo anche noi
dobbiamo solo scoprire qual è
arriviamo finalmente di rete al mio
perché
il mio perché è questo come sono
arrivata a questa domanda
di nuovo analizzando quelli
inconsapevole spinta cos'è che mi ha
portato a prendere quel telefono in quel
giorno cos'è che mi ha portato ad
abbandonare i miei mal riusciti
esperimenti di torte rustiche durante il
lockdown questa domanda qui volevo
rispondere a questa domanda qui Come
posso facilitare le cose per gli altri
ho fatto un ulteriore passo indietro mi
sono chiesta quante volte nella mia vita
lavorativa io avessi risposto a questa
domanda qui o quante volte rispondendo a
questa domanda qui io mi fossi sentita
realmente viva
la risposta è che è sempre stato così
è stato così
nell'ufficio stampa in cui lavoravo dove
portavo vestiti in giro per persone che
poi devono andare a farsi belli Durante
gli eventi durante le sfilate nella
società di consulenza dove ottimizzavamo
processi di aziende fatte di persone che
neanche conoscevo nella società
pubblicitaria dove aiutavo i miei
clienti a farsi notare nelle città del
mondo e poi nella mia idea di startup
fallita quella di dare un luogo a
giovani designer di Moda dove vendere e
far conoscere i propri prodotti
e poi appunto con la mia nuova
azienda quello che mi ha portato il mio
perché
mi piace chiamare il perché la super
soft skill di cui non sappiamo di essere
a conoscenza il perché è quello che ci
muove il fatto di avere un perché ad
oggi mi fa sentire al sicuro nel lavoro
che farò domani nell'idea che avrò e mai
realizzerò Io dovrò sempre rispondere al
mio perché avrò un obiettivo
ora Come trovare il nostro Perché ci
sono due situazioni una è la mia il mio
perché si è fatto strada a un certo
punto è esploso davanti a me nel
silenzio totale e io non ho più potuto
ignorarlo e in quel caso si è creata una
nuova opportunità lavorativa
Ma se alcuni di voi come me si sentono
si sono sentiti in una situazione dove
sono confusi dove volete trovare un po'
la vostra missione ho pensato ad una
piccola formula che potrete utilizzare
ora non è la formula della felicità non
ci prendiamo in giro ma può essere
d'aiuto i momenti di grande confusione
analizzate tutto quello che avete fatto
nella vita dall'esperienza più
insignificanti più piccole a quelle più
formative e completate questa frase per
ognuno
verbo all'infinito cosa per chi o
insieme a chi
ora non pensate ai compiti o alle
singole azioni che avete svolto ma
piuttosto a quello che vi rendeva felice
nel farle questi sono esempi di verbi
che si possono utilizzare per trovare il
nostro perché sono verbi all'infinito
perché il perché deve inglobare proprio
la nostra persona deve avere un'idea di
essere il tutto quindi aiutare per
esempio esaltare creare gestire
cambiare o vedere
e poi la cosa cosa state cercando di
risolvere questo potrà cambiare
Ovviamente in base alle varie
professioni che avete svolto i vari
progetti che avete svolto Ma non vi
preoccupate perché poi troverete una
quadra
e poi il vostro driver sono gli altri
siete voi stessi a chi state rivolgendo
tutto questo Ecco una volta che avrete
messo insieme tutte queste frasi
troverete un filo conduttore
quello sarà il vostro perché ho chiesto
a una persona che lavora con me una
ragazza che ha fatto molti lavori
diversi di fare questo esercizio
lei ha iniziato creando locandine per
amici che si esibivano a teatro ha poi
lavorato in una casa di produzione
pubblicitaria ora fa la videomaker ed è
in generale appassionato al mondo del
Digital mi ha chiamato dopo un paio di
giorni mi ha detto Carolina il mio
perché è fare da megafono per le storie
degli altri e raccontare le storie degli
altri ecco completando Questo esercizio
potete trovare il vostro perché
segnatevelo sul telefono scrivetelo su
un bigliettino che vi porterete in giro
o semplicemente tornate ci sempre nei
momenti in cui vi sentirete persi
ora
potete però utilizzarlo in situazioni un
po' più pratiche chiamiamole così
potrete utilizzarlo per convincere gli
altri e voi stessi del vostro valore ma
soprattutto
durante per esempio un colloquio di
lavoro un incontro di lavoro quando vi
verrà chiesto cosa potete portare in più
quali sono i vostri pregi Rispondete con
il vostro perché oppure in una
situazione un po' più informale durante
una cena quando vi chiederanno Ma tu che
lavoro fai e magari non avrete voglia di
rispondere perché non sapresti da dove
iniziare o perché fate troppe cose
diverse Allora Rispondete con il vostro
perché io risponderei facilito le cose
per gli altri li faccio splendere
potrebbero farvi qualche domanda in più
oppure potesse lasciarli a bocca aperta
concludo con una frase che mi ha detto
una persona a cui voglio molto bene che
ha notato un po' di nervosismo
probabilmente mentre stavo preparando
questo discorso come forse avrete notato
anche voi ed è questa sono tutti più
bravi di te ma nessuno è come te il
nostro perché è quello che ci rende
unici è quello che non ci fa avere paura
il mio perché è il motivo per cui oggi
sono qui davanti a voi raccontarvi la
mia storia
Grazie